taxi drivers here in las vegas and all  around the world have lost a lot of  business during the pandemic  but there is now a new effort in sweden  to keep them behind the wheel  cab drivers in stockholm are now trading  people  for packages they are delivering and  collecting coven 19 tests  from homes then they shuttle them over  to labs the process is socially  distanced of course  they're being called corona cabbies  they're making 37  an hour i feel very good  about doing this because the customers  that we drive the test to are very happy  that they don't  don't need to go anywhere well since the  pandemic started cab drivers have  delivered more than a quarter of a  million cova tests  and they'll continue until their usual  passengers are ready to ride again  interesting